sarah jane we just received this
statement from the metropolitan uh
police it's an update tells us some
stuff we knew already but the top line
really is the statement from the met
that says detectives investigating
allegations of breaches of covid19
regulations in downing street and
whitehall have begun to interview people
as witnesses as part of their ongoing
inquiries
no names no
no suggestion that it's the pm or the
chance for the exchequer or whether it's
downing street staff you remember that
there was a key civil servant martin
reynolds um who got the nickname party
marty
after sending out a bring your own booze
email well of course he's now been
shunted off to another job uh there's
been a big clear out of many of the
people
involved in all those allegations uh
number 10 the metropolitan police says
in addition to the detailed review of
all available material including
returned questionnaires you'll remember
that questionnaires were sent a few
weeks back to many of the people said to
be involved detectives from the
operation hillman investigation team
have started interviewing what they call
key witnesses key witnesses
to date over a hundred questionnaires
have been sent asking the recipients
about their participation in alleged
gatherings the questionnaires provided
recipients with the opportunity to give
an account of their involvement the
responses the responses form part of the
investigative material for the operation
recipients are given seven days to
respond as a result so far as a result
of the responses so far this is new
further individuals have been identified
further individuals have been identified
and questionnaires sent to them so in
other words the investigation is
widening
as the investigation continues we may
need to contact more people we may need
to contact more people as further
information comes to light and
it talks about the investigation
involving a significant amount of
investigative material the serving over
100 questionnaires and the need to
individually assess every response
the offences under consideration
comprise a number of elements the
legislation itself changed between the
event dates well we knew that obviously
there's various restrictions that came
in
we're progressing the investigation as
quickly as possible no hint as to how
long that might take now the met is
saying as yet we've not made any
referrals to the criminal records office
for the issuing of fixed penalty notices
remember there's been a lot of uh
suggestions by the polit the prime
minister's critics that if he was issued
with a
fixed penalty notice then he would be in
serious uh trouble and his position
would be uh uh come into question but no
um
referrals for fixed penalty notices have
been issued yet
uh however every questionnaire response
is being assessed alongside all
available evidence should this reach the
evidential threshold referrals will be
made so if there's enough evidence then
there will be fixed penalty notices and
um
um the
then is a little paragraph about the uh
london assembly police and crime
committee
um the how the commissioner that's
cressida set out the approach uh
guidelines and so on it seems that the
key piece of information here too really
one people are being interviewed could
be politicians could be present a number
10 staff could be former staff almost
certainly some of the key names that
we've heard already for example like
martin reynolds and other senior civil
servants or perhaps uh some of the
people who've now left number 10
like jack doyle a former press chief
there um
named in some of the reports uh taking
part but the other key thing here is
that it's
that further individuals have been
identified as a result of the police
inquiry and the police are saying we may
need to contact more people as further
information comes to light